Hey everybody, real quick. So in this
episode, we are going to discuss a
specific religious entity. And I want to
preface this that in no way, no means
are we attacking any individual, any
person that wholeheartedly, genuinely is
part of this religious entity and is
seeking out the truth. That's not our
aim. That's not our goal. We have high
regard and respect for anybody being
part of that. We are not attacking the
people. We are just discussing the
system as it is described in Bible
prophecy and end time prophecy. Okay,
let's dive in. Pope Francis has passed
away. And you know, it's never God's
intent for people to pass away. He
didn't want that in the first place.
It's because of sin came in the world
that this has happened. And it's a sad
ordeal when somebody passes away. You
know, I I believe that God's heart
breaks over having to witness that over
and over again, no matter who it is,
right? Um but you know, um when somebody
like this passes away and he's a very
well-known person, it gives us an
opportunity to kind of talk about his
life, what he was up to, what he stood
for. And that's something that we're
going to do today. And in this we are
going to discuss how actually the Roman
Catholic Church which he was the head of
is actually mentioned in Bible prophecy
which not a lot of people know. Yep. But
it's really interesting to talk about.
So Alex, you're here with us again today
and your brother James, you guys both
have your own channels, uh, Biblical
Hope and Heritage and Hope Ministries.
And Brian, you're here with us for the
first time and you are a frequent face
on Alex's channel, Heritage and Hope
Ministries. Definitely check out these
channels, but you're gonna dive deep
into um the Pope's life. Actually, we
all are. Yeah. So, what do you have for
us today? Well, you know, um as a
Protestant, I think we have a unique
perspective on world events and what
exactly the legacy of Pope Francis has
been. And it's not really our goal to
denigrate him per se, but to just
discuss his life and what his overall
work was about. Um, so a lot of people
don't know that popes, well, at least I
don't think they think of the fact that
a lot of popes have traditional names.
Right. Right. Uh, so his name was, uh,
am I saying this right? Jorge Mario
Burggoglio. So um, you know, one of the
things that's interesting about his
upbringing is he is the first Jesuit
pope. Okay. And uh so you know, you see
the IHS logo, that's the the symbol of
Jesuits right there. And then James,
who's who's this right here? You got
Ignatius of Loyola there. Okay. And uh
so you guys have done a a pretty recent
episode talking about Jesuits and
talking about Ignatius. We you know,
we've got a couple of episodes about
that on our channel. Actually, the first
one we ever did was with James and that
has like a hundred something thousand
views right now, which is doing pretty
good just talking about And then
Ignatius of Lyola is actually the
founder of the Jesuits. Yep. Um so
what's interesting is to look at some of
his history and it kind of talks about
how far up in the Jesuit ranks he got.
Um and you know it says in 1967 Burggoio
began his theological studies at
Basilades de philosophia and that was on
December in 1969 and he was ordained a
priest by Archbishop Rammon Jose
Castellano. He served as the master of
novicesis for the province there and
became a professor of theology. Buglio
completed his final stage of spiritual
training as a Jesuit churchian ship at
Akala de Hanarez, Spain and took final
vows as a Jesuit including the fourth
vow of obedience to missioning by the
pope on April 22nd 1973. So why why are
you emphasizing the fourth vow? What's
significant about that? There are very
few fourth vow Jesuits in the world.
Interesting. Okay. Um, and so that's
very high up in the ranks of Jesuits.
We're not talking like, well, you know,
I'm just kind of becoming acquainted
with Jesuits and like, yeah, I like
their teaching and I've been to a Jesuit
school and that type of thing. We're
talking like I'm a dedicated lifelong
that's my only pursuit is to be a
Jesuit. So, it's likely that they have
taken the Jesuit oath then, right?
Right. And that's that's uh something
that's interesting. And you actually
discussed the Jesuit oath in one of your
earlier videos that you guys just came
out with here recently. And you can
actually see um there's been articles
written about his Jesuit influence. So
uh you know there's this article right
here 10 years of ignation influence
under Francis. And again you can see the
the IHS the sun the sun the sun right
there on him. And if you look it a
little bit wider out it's not the
greatest picture but you can kind of
roughly make out that it says Ignatius
right there. that Jesuit influence
had a profound impact on his papacy and
what his goal was to accomplish. Um, you
know, there's a lot of interesting
quotes. There's been a lot of people
that have been against Jesuit influence
specifically. Uh, John Adams actually
said, "If ever any congregation of man
could merit eternal predition on earth
and in hell, it is the company of
Lyola." M you got to think that's like
some pretty profound statement right
there from John John Adams but Thomas
Jefferson
uh the third US president he said
Jesuits are a powerful order and never
were good citizens. Wow. So there was at
the founding of this of this country
there was a lot of discussion about
Jesuit influence and to be fair prior to
that those statements they had been
thrown out of multiple countries before
that. Oh yeah. No, they have. And so,
you know, and you can go kind of deeper
into the history if you look at some of
your videos that you guys have done on
that, right? And and so the the United
States, the government of the United
States in the early stages of this
country, they wanted to keep the Jesuits
out, but they realized they couldn't do
that and also encourage religious
freedom. They had to let them in, but
they didn't want to. Right. Yeah. Um, so
here's a little video. Let's go ahead
and play this and and see what he has to
say. And while he himself loved reading
books of romance novels, what he found
when he was recovering were lives of the
[Music]
saints. Lyola read books about the lives
of Roman Catholic saints, including
Dominic Goodsman, founder of the
Dominicans, the order that ran the
Inquisition. Lyola was influenced by
their zeal for Rome.
and their devotion to
Mary. And through all these visions, he
started getting the idea of how he could
live this kind of a new holy life and
dedication. But nonetheless, in his
recovery, he spent a year in a place
called Manresa in Spain in a cave and
started having these
experiences and he wrote all these notes
and under this kind of spiritual
guidance and I don't think it was God
that was guiding him. He came up with
this kind of a
training and in the end when he applied
this training to other people it was
like a brainwashing. I mean they
literally felt like enlightened people.
In fact they eventually got the name
alumbrados which in Latin would be
Illuminati enlightened
ones. The spiritual exercises of
Ignatius Loyola are continued among the
Jesuits and others even today. Yet
critics argue that his visions supported
heretical doctrines which are often
contrary to scripture.
The spiritual exercises of Ignatius of
Loyola are not just harmless exercises.
They're actually exercises that were
inspired by apparitions of Mary and
demonic doctrines that he'd received
from
[Music]
them. For Lyola, the visions he claimed
to have only confirmed the doctrines of
Rome and the papacy.
Shortly after their acceptance, the
Jesuits were called upon by Pope Paul
III to play a key role in the Council of
Trent, the first major event of the
Counterreformation. The council
denounced the Protestant reforms, in
particular, the teaching that salvation
is by faith in Jesus Christ alone.
The council declared, "If anyone saith
that faith alone in the divine promise
suffices for the obtaining of grace, let
him be anathema."
Yeah, I I think this is a pretty
powerful bit and there's a lot in it,
but you know, we have to summarize who
the Jesuits are. You know they were
founded by Ignatius of Lyola
but they were and there's historical
evidence for this. They were an order
that was supposed to counter the
reformation out of which Protestantism
came. Right? You know Protestants who
said hey we don't agree with what the
Roman Catholic Church is teaching. It
was a ch church state power. They were
the only ones ruling the world. They
were ruling over kings and they were
basically telling people this is what
you should believe and the Bible is
forbidden. You cannot read it for
yourself and have an understanding from
the Bible for yourself what you believe.
Well, Ignatius of Lyola, you know, his
one of the principles advocated for in
his spiritual exercises was uh what I
see as black I will believe is white if
the hierarchy of the church so defines
it. I might have those colors mixed up,
but uh yeah, you you had to be a corpse
um in the hands of your
superior kadaavver like it was you were
to turn over all of your thinking
capacity to somebody else. This would
have precluded any of the actions of the
Bereans in testing for themselves to see
whether or not the apostles were
speaking according to the word of God.
But the Jesuits would very much like you
to avoid following the footsteps of the
Bereans and testing every doctrine by
the word of God. Mhm. Yeah. They wanted
you to be robots orders, right? So, you
know, this is who Pope Francis was a
part of. Not just to a light degree, but
the fourth order, you know, he's deeply
into it. So, one thing that's
interesting is discussing the Jesuit
oath. Now, the Jesuit oath a lot,
there's been a lot of controversy about
it. This is a document that surfaced a
long time ago and a lot of people have
said, "Oh, it's a forgery. Oh, it's not
real. We can't verify it. It's not
official." But the very nature of the
oath and which we're I'll show it here
in just a second. But the very nature of
the oath would mean it would have to be
secret. Mhm. Right. And we have enough
other background evidence which if you
check out our previous video that we did
with our ancient documents, our Jesuit
books that we brought in, you can easily
make the case for why the principles
contained inside this Jesuit oath right
here were legitimate. Mhm. I think Yeah.
Um and so would Pope Francis have uh
sworn this oath? I don't know. Um I
think that it it's not outside the realm
of possibility at all. Yeah, I agree.
But we don't know for sure. Um, you
know, only God can judge his heart. So,
um, but there's some statements in here
that are are just positively
um, horrific to look at, which I'm not
going to sit here and read through all
the different statements of it. If you
want to, you can pause the video and
kind of take a look at some of those
things yourself, but it's it's horrific
language. And basically, the whole
thought was to crush out any notion of
Protestantism with any means necessary.
What I find interesting is that at the
top it says,"I do further promise and
declare that notwithstanding I am
dispensed with to assume my religion
heretical for the propagation of mother
church's interest which is the Catholic
Church to keep secret and private all
her agents councils from time to time as
they interest me and and not divulge
directly or indirectly by word writing
or circumstances whatever." So, you
know, this was by all means a secret
society. Of course, you know, they were
they had to operate in secret. And in
fact, what I find interesting about the
the Jesuits is that when you read the
book, The Great Controversy, and and we
can put a link in the description for
whoever wants to read it. It's just
based on uh it's it's based on history,
right? As historians book, it's a
history book. It it's it it shows you in
there how and and again, it's not just
in that book. This is history in general
that they were supposed to look like
proper Protestant Christians, act like
them, do the good deeds, visit
hospitals, um visit the sick to but then
to be undetected among the Protestants
to plant seeds to point them back to
Catholicism, bring them back into the
fold, right?
And it's just interesting that that goes
directly handinhand with the Jesuit oath
as well. Well, and there's direct
evidence of that. You know, you look at
Manuel Lakuna's work that he published
under the pen name Rabbi Ben Ezra. He
literally assumed the position of a Jew
exactly like what the extreme Jesuit
Oath talks about stooping so low as to
become a Jew among the Jews. Right?
That's exactly what they what he did
when he
wrote and
glor is it was to assume that guys is to
get the evangelicals to buy it more
likely. Right. So we have evidence that
the ideals that were in this were
carried out. Mhm. Okay. So but kind of
going on from there, let's play another
little video clip and kind of take a
look at this. We must hold fast to the
following principle. What seems to me
white, I will believe black. If the
hierarchical church so
defines, the initial weapon of the
counterreform was based in doctrine and
theology. But when that proved
ineffective, the Jesuits looked to the
use of force and developed a network of
spies and
assassins. At some point, they
established a secret oath for those who
reached the higher levels of the order.
The Jesuit oath has been known for more
than 200 years and remains a point of
controversy with some questioning its
very
existence. Nevertheless, the oath has
been published repeatedly in books and
articles and can be found among the
records of the Library of Congress and
in the National Library of Australia.
While the full oath is much longer, here
we include those parts that might be
considered the most
important. It begins with a Jesuit
superior speaking to a younger initiate
who is already a Jesuit priest, but is
now brought under what is called the
fourth vow of the order.
My son, heretofor you have been taught
to act the
[Music]
dissembler, but you have not yet been
invested with all that is necessary to
command in the army of
Lyola. For none can command here who has
not consecrated his labors with the
blood of the heretic. For without
shedding of blood, no man can be
saved. Therefore, repeat after me.
I now in the presence of almighty God,
the blessed virgin Mary, and to you, my
ghostly father, the superior general of
the society of Jesus, declare and swear
that his holiness the pope is Christ's
vice regent, and that he hath power to
depose heretical kings, princes, states,
and governments, all being illegal
without his sacred quate
[Music]
confirmation. I furthermore promise and
declare that I will, when opportunity
presents, make and wage relentless war
secretly or openly against all heretics,
Protestants, and liberals to extrapate
and exterminate them from the face of
the whole earth.
Go ye then into all the world and take
possession of all lands in the name of
the pope. He who will not accept him as
the vicor of Jesus and his vice regent
on earth let him be accursed and
exterminated.
So there's a possibility that if he was
a fourth vow Jesuit he might have said
the Jesuit oath and he might have been
part of this order. I mean, we don't
know exactly what all happened behind
the scenes, but we don't know. Um, but
there's a lot of historical evidence to
back this up. Yeah. Right. You know,
absolutely. And if someone tells you who
they are, believe them. Mhm. You know,
there's there's an old saying there. And
just the fact as well that there's
there's four steps at least it seems
like that kind of goes into the secrecy
as well because that gets into secret
societies. They have levels to them. You
know, the initiates don't know anything.
And we're going to talk more about that
here in a second, but you would assume
that the lower level Jesuits aren't
brought into that until they're trusted
and groomed and then they're they're,
you know, you get to the point to where
maybe you do potentially shed innocent
blood. That's right. Right. Well, okay.
So, then let's kind of shift gears and
look at how his legacy is being viewed
by the media. Um, so he's died. Uh,
let's kind of talk about that. Um, you
know what's interesting is that a lot of
the Freemasons, actually the Freemason
Freemason lodge actually hailed Pope
Francis work as deeply resonant with
their principles. H doesn't surprise me.
No, not really. And they specifically
mentioned Fellletudi. I don't know if I
said that right, James. I think you
might have a few things to Yeah,
fertility was kind of interesting in the
sense that uh it did elevate those three
uh values not only associated with
Freemasonry but also the French
Revolution. So there were a lot of
people even in some of the conservative
Catholic side that noted that uh that
you know why is Pope Francis heralding
the battlecry of the French Revolution
and I think it's very interesting in
where he takes that in fatellituti
because he goes on under that chapter
heading to state that fraternity is not
only a climate of respect for individual
liberties or of a certain
administratively guaranteed equality.
He goes on to state that equality is
achieved or not rightly achieved by an
abstract proclamation that all men and
women are equal. Now, where do we hear
that statement? All men and women are
equal.
I mean, that that's in the Constitution.
Yeah. That that that comes from American
documents. So, we're shading we're
casting shade here on American
principles. Mhm. Mhm. And what we're
trying to cultivate is fraternity in
this
document. Where does that lead to? If
you downplay individual liberty and
individual rights and elevate fraternity
and the common good, the principles of
the common good. Ultimately, it takes
you down the path for Catholicism to
deny individual liberty and to establish
uh more of an interest in the in the
goods of of the majority or the needs of
the majority. But who defines what is
the common
good? Rome is ultimately the one who's
going to want to define who is and who
gets the common good benefit. Yeah, this
is Catholic social doctrine 101. It goes
back to is it Vatican 2? Was this was
that when that was initially kind of
presented? Well, it's not just Vatican
2, but I mean you can you can trace this
all the way back to, you know, the
Middle Ages where individual liberty was
very very low and you didn't you didn't
have freedom of the press then. You
didn't have the freedom to even read the
the word of God in your own language. I
mean, if you were a heretic, you could
be persecuted and put to death. In fact,
if you were excommunicated, that was
basically an open season that anybody
could kill you without any retribution.
Well, Vatican 2 is essentially a plan of
how to get back there from what I
understand. Is that correct? In Vatican
2, there's uh there's some complexities
about Vatican 2 that uh are interesting.
Uh one of the things that I would I've
observed from Vatican 2 is it it
continues the idea of religious
submission of mind and will to the
magisterium of the Roman pontiff even
when he is not speaking ex Cathedral. M
oh so you had to submit to the pope in
all
things and it must be shown in such a
way that even his judgments made they
had to be be sincerely adhered to. It
wasn't just a case of you could disagree
and not go along with the pope, but you
actually had to adhere to the judgments,
but also that individual bishops do not
enjoy the prerogative uh although they
don't enjoy the prerogative of
infallibility, they nevertheless
proclaim Christ's doctrine
infallibly whenever even though
dispersed through the world but still
maintaining the bond of communion among
themselves and with the successor of
Peter. So it still elevated papal
infallibility and religious submission
to the pope.
Now what we see here is principles once
again though with Pope Francis that are
trying to shift America and attack
individual liberties in the constitution
to nullify that and return the United
States and and and get her to bow down
at the feet of Rome. Right. Yeah. You
mentioned uh and I may not say this
right, the ex Kataragra. Excathe.
Excathedral, which is
essentially a pope can say something and
if it's not Excathedra, he can lie. It
doesn't matter. But if it's ex
Cathedral, then that's it. That's what I
understand, right? Then that's that
that's the way they like to sell it to
Protestants who would come along and and
attack them for papal infallibility
claims. Uh we have the the claim, well,
that wasn't said ex Cathedral, therefore
the pope could have aired there.
um it's kind of a way to escape charges
that are brought against the pope. But
as we've seen here in
Lumentium, it's actually they actually
admit that obedience has to extend even
outside of decrees that are excedra.
Therefore, the whole claim is it's it's
really nonsense. If you go back to the
the time of the
reformation, infallibility was
proclaimed all the time, right? And you
had to obey the pope. I mean regardless
there there was no uh you know you don't
you don't have uh really ex cathedral
being promoted as well only some
positions by the pope are infallible. No
you had to listen to all of them. Well
you know it's such an erroneous concept
because it's like what if I had like a
relationship with my wife but it's like
well I didn't have my hand on the Bible
so nothing I said mattered. It's like
what? Like come on. like to to to to say
that there's oh it's only when it's ex
cathedra does it really count? It's like
that's such a strange notion like you
know I don't know I mean by the bi the
Bible talks about like by their fruits
you shall know them you know if if
they're not speaking according to the
word is there light in them if you go if
you go back to 2 Thessalonians 2 when
the man of sin sits in the temple of God
showing himself that he is God when he
sits there the word is
cathedral is actually I mean alluded to
in 2 Thessalonians 2 where the man of
sin tries to tries to sit in the temple
of
Interesting. That's good. You know, kind
of discussing Freemasonry a little bit
further. It's interesting because the
Vatican has actually said that it's a
grave sin for Freemasons or for, you
know, Catholics to to join the
Freemasons. So, you know, but
despite this statement by the Vatican
saying that, you know, Catholics should
not be Freemasons, uh there was a
Vatican intelligence officer that
confirmed Pope Francis is a liberal
Freemason. And this was actually a chief
Vatican intelligence officer. remember
it was a very high ranking uh and this
is uh Argentinian press that are
essentially discussing this how they had
this conversation and that uh this
officer essentially said that not only
was he a Freemason but Pope Francis also
is a Freemason a couple of weeks ago u
we dropped a documentary about the
chosen which was our second documentary
that we did and um in it I mean even if
you're not interested in the chosen I
highly recommend you watch this because
this is uh it goes really in depth into
the Jesuits and the Freemasons and and
all the secret societies. Anyway, so I I
showed this document in there. It's from
um a Masonic magazine from the 19th
century and they said themselves, "Yeah,
so the Freemasons, they're actually run
by the Jesuits."
But the Jes Freemasons just don't know
it. The high up ones, they know the
Jesuits run the Freemasons. Yep. They
also run our schools in Hollywood. Yeah.
Uh we have a little video clip here um
kind of talking about some of this
secret society stuff and I thought this
was this is illuminating. You got to
watch this. The fourth revolution
theorized by Claus
Schwra and the family of international
finance
find not a neutral
spectator which would itself already be
an unheard of
thing. but actually a zealous
cooperator who abuses his own moral
authority in order to
support
Adesta outside the church. The project
of the dissolution of traditional
society while Adid are within the
church. He
pursues the project of the demolition of
the church in order to replace her with
a phil philanthropic
organization of Masonic
inspiration and it is candidous.
This applied to both to civil and
ecclesiastical
world confirming the bum shery the
criminal
conspiracy
between the deep state and the deep
[Music]
church. It seems to me that in this
conspiracy the role of the
Jesuit has been
decisive. It is no coincidence that for
the first time in history, a religious
of the society of Jesus is seated on the
throne of Peter.
So who is this? This is an archbishop
who's actually excommunicated. Is it is
it Vano? Carlos Carlos I think that's
right. Yeah. He's critical of the pope.
He's very He was very He was actually
actually why he was excommunicated was
for being critical of Pope Francis. M um
so you've had multiple people kind of
insinuate that Pope Francis is a
Freemason. Um so you have right here
that's a soon to be uh Pope Francis with
Pope Benedict and that's a Masonic
handshake right there. And then he's
also with uh Queen Elizabeth uh prior to
the hack. And this is the hidden hand.
This is also a masonic sign also known
as the sign of the master of the second
veil. Um, and you can see George
Washington, Napoleon, and then Stalin as
well. They were all Freemasons, too.
They were all Freemasons. And here's
some more as well. You might recognize
some of these people. Ted Cruz, Obama,
and that's actually Anthony Fouchy who
made a spectacle. There's a video if you
look on YouTube where he walks out in a
press conference and does this and kind
of looks around the room, you know, and
then puts his hand down. So, so some
people might think, oh, this is just a
bunch of bogus. But I I actually knew of
or knew a former Freemason once. We
tried to interview him for the show and
our audio was corrupted and we never
actually aired it. But he was saying
this is a real thing that they do in
Freemasonry where they have hand
signals. So for example, if they go to a
court and you're a criminal and you know
the judge is a Freemason, you throw up a
certain sign that they know and they'll
let you go. But but like he was in his
grandpa was a high up Freemason, his
great-grandfather was a high up
Freemason and he was a Freemason. So
this is not coming from a, you know,
some random source like he knew about
this and he confirms this uh the the the
signs that they do. No, that's real. I
think they like to flaunt it in your
face. It's for the goyam or the sheep,
you know, the people who aren't
enlightened, you know, not not in the
elite lab level that they consider
themselves. Yeah. And there's also an
occult outlook that they have to tell
you these things. They have to show you
what they're going to do and tell you
what they're going to do. And if you
don't respond, then it's essentially
giving them permission in their mind. So
there's this oult mindset where they
have to to kind of telegraph what
they're going to do. And it's
interesting, too, like I mean, I don't
wear suits. You guys wear suits. How
often do you really stand there like
with your hand in your pocket like you
know, unless you're like scratching
yourself quickly or something? I mean, I
might reach in and grab something, but
I'm never like just sitting there like,
"Ah, yes." Like like right here like
that's odd. Especially in the public
eye. uh this this with Ted Cruz, he's
actually on the other side of him is
would be Trump and then Jeb Bush and you
know they both have their hand over and
because they were doing like the pledge
of allegiance or or whatever beforehand
but that slip of the hand inside that's
purposeful and he knows cameras are on
him. So that is 100% on purpose. So you
know kind of talking then about some of
his background then what happened? You
know we know that he caught pneumonia um
and he battled pneumonia for a long
time. It's really interesting to see
that they actually released this photo
right here of him dressed in plains
clothes because, you know, a public
figure like him, you you kind of have
this person in your mind as like this
elevated position, this elevated, you
know, stature and and regal robe and
everything, but to see him brought down
to he's just a little old man wearing
oxygen, you know, but being very
carefully guarded. Um, we know that he
had pneumonia for a while. Um, and we
know that he does not look good in this
picture. He does not look good. No, you
know, we're both medical professionals
and I think you would agree with me,
Alex. He looks very frail. Like he's
he's on his last legs there. Yes, very
much so. And you can actually see that
in this next video clip, which isn't the
best quality, but let's just watch it
for just a second.
[Applause]
[Music]
We're walking on
[Applause]
So, so I mean he looks completely worn
out there. Yeah. Well, supposedly he had
a it started with a stroke right later
on later on that night. I mean looking
at that video cognitively like he does
not look right in that video to me at
all. No. Well, and I you know I think we
can see he was approaching the end of
his life for sure which you know it's
not outside the re realm of possibility
if you have somebody with pneumonia puts
a lot of strain on the heart you're more
prone to arhythmias which can cause
stroke and so it's not not surprising at
all that he passed away from a stroke
but he's to me he looks like someone who
may have even had a stroke before that
or maybe right then just just the way
he's acting. Y there's a lot of people
that are mourning his passing and you
know I certainly feel for those people
who are mourning for him. Um, what's
interesting is to kind of discuss how
they would pronounce popes dead
previously. Now, they didn't do that
from all accounts that I could find this
time, but in the past, they would take a
silver hammer and they would come to the
pope who had died and they would say the
pope's baptismal name and hit him on the
head ceremonial ceremonially three times
while calling out his baptismal name.
And if he didn't answer or respond, then
he was considered dead. That's odd. It
is odd. It's very like ceremonial, very
like, you know, where did the hammer
come from, too? Where's this symbol? I I
guarantee you there's probably some
deeper symbolism there, but they don't
do it currently. Apparently, they
diagnose it based off EKG. But have you
guys seen this movie or heard of this
movie? We've made a video about it.
Link in the description.
So, this is Conclave. Um, and it's
basically a drama that talks about
replacing the pope. Mhm. That's what the
conclave is in the Vatican. It's that's
what it's called is where the cardinals
come together and they vote in secret on
the new pope. Right. So, so Brian, what
did you think about the conclave? What
did you think about how how this kind of
set the stage? I guess spoiler alert if
I'm going to give my thoughts on because
I have watched the whole thing.
the whole thing through. Um, it was very
interesting to sit and analyze it. Um,
and of course it's not a coincidence
that it came out this year, right?
January, what? December or January? It
was the end of it was last last year,
but this year it won a Golden Globe in
January. It was the end of last year.
It's it's fairly very recent. So, of
course, they're kind of telegraphing,
you know, there's no coincidence at all.
But as far as the movie itself, you
know, there's there's kind of they go
into some of the secrecy and some of the
politics and the conservative versus
liberal. Um, but what's very interesting
is the pope that is ultimately elected
at the end. So, they kind of have this
this whole, like I said, back and forth.
And it's a dark horse candidate that no
one's talking about. Um, and he was
actually put in place by the previous
pope, the the pope that died in the
movie, set all this up in motion before
he passed. Um, and um, basically you
find out that this new pope has a dark
secret that he's transgender. Mhm. Um,
which I don't think is a coincidence
either. And you can kind of point
towards, you know, well, that's just the
progressive progressivism of Hollywood,
but if you look into the to the origin
of androgyny, it goes there's nothing
new under the sun. It go it has pagan
roots and goes all the way back. Um even
if you look at Baffomet as an
androgynous god. Um so to coronate um
someone like that, I think is very
purposeful. Mhm. It it actually goes
back to the Jesuit creed that we read in
one of the uh videos back in the day um
where it talked about them believing in
father and mother like both father the
god the father and Mary as per
hermaphrodites
like that was actually part of the creed
from I think wandosa
um gathered up. So yeah, I mean that's
actually something that's been featured.
Mhm. Right. In some of their older
documents. Yeah. And to be clear, I'm
not attacking anyone who may identify as
transgender at all. But um the reality
is even if you go
into websites from transgender people,
they will tell you that the roots go all
the way back. This isn't new. Uh the
Jesuitical creed. I just wanted to
confirm that real fast. Yeah. Here we
go. I believe in two gods whereof one is
father mother metaphorically according
to eternal generation the other
metaphorically mother and father
according to the temporal generation
which is in consequent here that the
common term father mother may be equally
attributed to god and the blessed virgin
as if they were both hermaphrodites and
that's from Juan de bal uh no alonso de
farus tatani actually uh had that Jesuit
creed interesting Yeah, I I did not know
that. Yeah. So, you know, kind of going
forward from here, it's interesting to
see the world's reaction. You have even
people that were historically at odds
with with Pope Francis are going to be
going to his funeral, paying homage,
paying respect to Pope Francis. You
know, Trump has made no secret that he
was not a huge fan of Pope Francis. And
yet, he's going to be going to the
funeral. He's also written an executive
order like the day that the pope died or
the day after that all the US flags need
to be hung. Yeah. Half passed. Right.
Yeah. So I was like that's really
interesting given that the history of
the country is that like no we don't
want the Jesuits even in our country.
Yeah. When did it happen last time? When
another president died, right? Like
which is your own countryman, the leader
of your people. And now it's like
different country. Vatican is a country,
right? And his wife is also Catholic. Oh
yeah. So yeah, he's telling you who his
master is. Well, that's the other
interesting thing is that you look at
the presidents of the whole world, they
every single time a new president comes
in at the United States, they go visit
the Vatican at some point and they come
and visit them. And if you look at the
when Trump and Melania and Ivanka Trump
and her husband all visited President uh
visited the Pope, the ladies were
dressed in black with black veils. Yeah.
If you look up the reasoning behind it,
there's actually Catholic sources that
say, "Well, this is a way to humble
yourself in front of the Pope." And it's
only royal women and I think they have
to have been born into the Catholic
faith, something like that, that can be
dressed in white. And it's like an
honor, but the pope has to grant you the
honor. So there's a lot of control. And
there's a lot of power that the pope has
over world leaders the same ways we're
seeing in the dark ages. Interesting.
Yeah. Didn't know that. Well, and I'm
sure you guys probably saw that JD Vance
was he was one of the last people to
meet with Pope Francis. He's a Catholic.
He's Catholic. I would have loved to
have been a fly on the wall for that
meeting. I don't think we'll ever know
what was really said in it, but and
they've been highly critical of each
other uh because of the immigration
policies, especially here recently. So,
you know, this is not Yes, he's
Catholic, but that's not like at least
the appearance is that they weren't
friends. Yet, here he goes to pay homage
to him right before he dies. Um, you
know, you have Biden, uh, who also said,
you know, he he was an open fan of Pope
Francis, so this isn't exactly a
surprising headline. See, how she's
dressed in black again, had like a veil,
everything. Very interesting. That's
interesting. Yeah. Um, you had Barack
Obama who talked about how he was a rare
leader who, you know, basically, you
know, talking about how how good of a
person he was. So, but not everybody was
so positive. So, you actually had
Marjorie Taylor Green here. Um, and
right after the pope died, she she I
think it was on the X, she said um that
evil is being defeated by the hand of
God. Now, she didn't say any names. She
wasn't like, "Oh, Pope Francis died and
this is what happened." She just said,
"Evil is being defeated by the hand of
God." But like right after he died, but
like right after. And so what's
interesting is as a result of that,
there's a Catholic group calling for
Marjorie Taylor Green's censure over
Pope Francis comments. And so, so read
this little snippet right here. In this
letter, Catholic League President
William Donahue said Green had a history
of slandering Catholics and they
previously asked the committee to
sanction Green for comments she made in
2022. Donahoo said that Green's recent
post about defeating evil was aimed at
the Holy Father. I'm writing to you in
my capacity as president of the nation's
largest civil Catholic civil rights
organization to I have one request. Do
what you can to have Representative
Marjorie Taylor Green censured. Dun who
said so much for making religion a test
of office. Right. Doesn't the
Constitution warn about that? Well,
exactly. But the the most ironic part of
it is this is coming from somebody who's
a Catholic civil
rights leader. And so it's like, okay,
so there's no free speech, right? Now,
I'm not saying I agree with, you know,
immediately coming out with like some
kind of hurtful comment. Like I'm not
saying I agree with 100% of Marjorie
Taylor Green, but I'm just saying like
to to say to have an anonymous post
that's not aimed at anybody. It doesn't
name anybody and then just say, "Oh, we
got to censure her." Like, what? Yeah.
Like, that's not free speech. I agree
with you that free speech goes both
ways. Right. Right. Like if it We have
so many people in the comments who
regularly say, "I don't agree with you.
I know you guys do, too." Right. That's
okay. That's okay. You can do that. Mhm.
Right. Um, but overall, the majority of
people were were talking about how
beneficial his legacy was. Um there's
all kinds of different faith leaders who
are saying that he made his mark. Um and
there's even the living Lutheran right
here. Um in particular, we will remember
Pope Francis for his significant
contributions to the dialogue of life
between Lutheran and Catholics,
advancing the joint declaration on the
doctrine of justification. We will
recall with amazement his participation
alongside the Lutheran World Federation
in a joint ecumenical commemoration of
the 500th anniversary of the Reformation
on October 31st, 2016. So one of the big
things that we have to highlight of Pope
Francis legacy is his ecumenism.
How he tried to unite everybody. And a
lot of people will say that's a positive
thing. I mean we have a picture here of
him. they were showing him the the
Quran, right? And he's sitting there
allowing this person to speak to him
about that, you know, as a as a world
leader. Um Francis made a statement
basically against them burning the Quran
and basically said you shouldn't burn
any book that's considered holy by, you
know, a group of people, right? Coming
from the institution that did mass book
burnings and tried to keep people from
reading the Bible, being literate. Yep.
Um, and they're promoting this. This is
in the name of ecumenicalism, right? But
do we really think once they get
everybody together and the e this
ecumenical movement gets to wherever
they're trying to lead it, do you think
they're still going to allow that level
of freedom? Nope. We've already seen
that with Marjgery Taylor Green.
Exactly. Exactly. Right. we have um
Russian President Vladimir Putin who
also has voiced his condolences
um and he's throughout the years of his
pontificate he actively promoted the
development of dialogue between the
Russian Orthodox and the Roman Catholic
churches again having that sentiment of
ecumenism trying to bring everybody
together under one banner basically you
also had Turkish President Taip Erdogan
um a respected statesman Pope Francis
was also a spiritual leader who valued
dialogue between different faith groups.
There it is, you know, talking.
Everybody recognized that he had deep um
ecumenical ties all over the place. And
this guy is supposedly I I'm assuming
being the president of of Turkey, he's
probably Muslim. But I think it's
important to remember Walter Vith
actually has a very good video on this
in the total onslaught series that shows
um at least makes a case that the Muslim
religion was came out of Catholicism.
Yes, that's an interesting Yeah. So,
they're not as far apart as you may
think. And and he also shows how the um
you
know the structure of how these secret
societies came about. Again, the Jesuits
were overseeing the the Freemasons and
the Knights Templars came before all of
that, which is also a Catholic order.
But how in that whole structure of all
of these different secret societies, you
can also find Muslim secret societies as
well. And on in in line or in in context
of these Catholic secret societies,
Christianity and the secret societies,
we could then summarize it as follows.
The old Babylonian religion gave rise to
cabalism via the scenes and others.
Nnosticism came into existence and
nasticism was founded by Simon Maggas.
This comes from no other source than
history lami and uh byas Levi. Wow,
that's a high Masonic source.
So,nosticism founded by Simon Magus.
Then
thisnosticism with its secret doctrine
was eventually over time through many
intermediary
organizations carried over to the
Knights Templars. And the Knights
Templars were a group
of a Roman Catholic order if you like
that were set over the temple site to
protect it. And they had strong links to
Islamic societies, the Ismiles, the
Karmatites, the Fatimites, the Duisers,
and the
Assassins. And these are very very
interesting, and we'll be dealing with
them when we talk about the Islamic
connection. what the secret societies
actually teach. Just like the Templars
had two doctrines, one for the Goyam,
the uninitiated, and one for the
insiders, and the two diametrically
opposed to each other. So the secret
societies of Islam do exactly the same
thing, but that's another lecture. Now
the Templars, they had their secret
inner information inculcated in the
Rossians and the Jesuits.
The Jesuits again formed and created
Freemasonry. And Freemasonry was created
as the Protestant arm of the Roman
Catholic Church. Unbeknown to them,
beguiled, fooled, if you like, into
doing the work that Rome wanted them to
do so that Rome could sit in the
background while Freemasonry did it for
them. And then it wasn't them, it was
them. And it was mainly Protestants that
were doing it. and not Rome. Very
clever. Very, very clever indeed.
Interesting. And I I talked to someone
who went to Israel within the last few
years and they basically said their
interaction with some of the the um
Muslim Arabs over there. They're a lot
more friendly towards Catholics than
they are Christians of other
denominations. Well, it's interesting if
you go back to Burke McCarti's book, The
Suppressed Truth of the Assassination of
Abraham Lincoln, she talked about when
the Jesuits had been kicked out of Japan
by the Shoguns that they were
re-entering under the guise of Muslim
clerics. Ah, interesting. Okay. So, they
have they have a history of utilizing
them to their right to their ends. Ult
ultimately all roads point to Rome.
That'd be fair. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, you had the Iran president uh who
congratulated Pope Francis on the birth
of Jesus Christ, which is really
interesting, which is fascinating
because again, Iran like hate
Christianity. They will cut you down if
you speak against their government or
look at they're both in a room together
and they're both speaking at the
Vatican. Yeah. Well, this is these two
are different. This is No, this one this
one though is Pope Francis Iranian
president meet face to face at the
Vatican. Yes. And then this guy here,
he's the next president who came after
the the one on the right. Um and then he
uh he congratulates on the Pope Francis
on the birth of Jesus Christ. So very
odd. Right. Right. And you had the Dubai
seek uh Muhammad bin Rashid al-Makum
um talking about his legacy of humility
and interfaith unity.
So you you have all these different
people recognize him as bringing people
together. Is there anything wrong with
that?
I
well, you know, from a Bible prophecy
perspective, the harlot of Revelation 17
has many pearls,
but per Contra in the gospel, there's
one pearl of great price. M so when you
got this when you got this ecumenical
movement with all of these different
religions and uh
ultimately not condemning or calling out
sin but accepting everybody. Yeah,
you're downgrading the requirements of
God's law. You're downgrading the the
definition of truth. Um you also had
here um the LWF giving thanks to the
life and legacy of Pope Francis. Um, and
they urged Lutheran and Catholics to
move forward together with confidence as
pilgrims of hope. Where did the Lutheran
come from? Martin Luther who protested
against the system. Yeah, exactly. And
then, you know, just going piggybacking
off of what you were saying about the
ecumenicalism and if it's okay or not. A
lot of people say, well, Jesus said he
wants everybody to be united, which it's
true, but if you read the context of
John 17, he said, it says, sanctify them
by your truth. Your word is truth.
Right? So, if our unity is not based on
truth, which is the word of God, we
cannot unite. Right? We we want to be
united in Jesus. And Jesus according to
John 1 is the word, right? And the word
according to John 17 is truth. But you
know, you you do have this big push. You
have Christianity today saying that Pope
Francis was the friend to
evangelicals. So this has been a
concept, a theme that you've been seeing
over the last several years. I have a
clip here from Tony Palmer and he's
talking um to some Lutheran here about
the Protestant Reformation and their
protest. So let's watch this just real
quick.
pastor friends. If there is no more
protest, how can there be a Protestant
church? Maybe now we're all Catholics
again, but we are reformed. We're
Catholic in the universal sense. We are
not protesting the doctrine of salvation
by the Catholic Church anymore. We now
preach the same gospel. We now preach
you're saved by grace through faith
alone. The word alone was the argument
for 500 years. The word alone is there.
You can read it yourself. The protest is
over. The protest is over. So James,
what do you think about his assertion
there that they're saved by faith alone?
Not only the Council of Trent teaches uh
in opposition, but also so does so does
the Catechism as well.
Right. And so it goes back to that
earlier argument that we were talking
about at the very beginning about how
that was the sticking point where if you
believed in faith alone, you were
anathema. Um, you know, we discussed
that at the beginning of the
presentation. You know, we've seen a lot
of changes in the Catholic Church over
the years. Um, this is kind of kind of
uh what you think of when you think of
the Roman Catholic Church. You have all
these priests here and you have this
pomp, this circumstance, this, you know,
all these different traditions that are
associated with it. What kind of stands
out to you in this picture?
The red and purple. The red and purple.
Right. So, where do we find that kind of
concept of red and purple? Does that
does that ring any bells? Isn't it
Revelation 17? It It's Revelation and it
talks about how there is purple and
scarlet. Mhm. Right. And so we know that
the Roman Catholic Church, as
Protestants, we recognize the Roman
Catholic Church as a fulfillment of
Bible prophecy specifically, that it is
that beast that would seek to wear out
the saints, right? Mhm. Um, in addition
to that, a lot of people have forgotten
what Catholicism sort of looked like,
felt like over the years. Um, it was
traditional to have the the the most
pomp, the most circumstance, the most
ornate. And these are kind of not the
best photos because they're very old.
Because you don't see this stuff much
anymore. You might see it in a museum if
you go to it, but you don't see this as
a representation of the current Catholic
Church. You have these tiaras, these
crowns that would make even the most um
rich earthly monarch jealous, right?
With all studded with jewels. Um, you
have these robes just decked out in
gold. You have, you know, these these
popes would be carried around on these
beers carried by people down below. Did
you ever see Pope Francis doing this?
No, did not. Right. Even more recently
when you have had deaths of other popes,
you see them decked out with uh you know
the the the ornate robes and I don't you
you can recognize some of our former
presidents here. Multiple of them
actually uh kneeling in front of the
pope which is interesting. Um but
instead you have Pope Francis who most
traditionally was seen in white. Mhm. A
simple cap. Mhm. So the question is
is has the Catholic Church
changed? Has it has it made it you know
we had Vatican 2 in the 1960s right? We
had this this large meeting that took
place where they decided where they were
going where the trajectory of the
Catholic Church was going. And you had a
lot of things that were done away with
at the time. The Latin mass was
abolished and you've actually had new
styles of singing that have come about.
you know, back then you would typically
have the the typical, you know, kind of
ethereal Catholic uh cathedral kind of,
you know, um uh singing without
instruments or maybe just a pipe organ.
But now you've had the addition of like
traditional regular music, right?
There's videos out there of Catholic
priests, you know, going on stage with
drums and guitars and everything else.
You've had this adapting of it to the
modern age. But does that mean that any
of the principles contained therein have
changed? If you take one look at the
architecture of Rome, that was her motus
operandi all along was to uh join
together and synchretatize with the
surrounding religions and paganism and
incorporate that within her religion. So
if you go back to, you know, all of the
Assyrian and Babylonian artifacts, the
all of that back in the history of Rome,
it was always to syncretize with other
religions. And so when you see the
modern world shifting this direction,
Rome's just going to go right along with
it. Right? So it's kind of like a
chameleon changing its spots to kind of
fit in with the new landscape, if you
will. Well, we want to be careful there
because the Bible teaches that can a
leopard change its spots and it
describes this beast power in Revelation
as having leopard-like spots. Indicating
indicating therefore that
the underlying principles of Rome do not
change. Her her bloody character in the
past is the same today and when given
opportunity she will commit those same
crimes again. Right. Yeah. And we we
should also remember the Jesuit order
was an order in secret, right? So now
some people are openly Jesuit but their
practices are still secret and some are
Jesuit and you won't even know it. Um
but that was an order that was supposed
to like you were saying like like a
chameleon, right? like they will become
like the Protestants on the outside and
do all the good works and do all the
good things and show this humility but
it's all this auise to pull people back
to Roman Catholicism. I think Francis
unfortunately has done a very great job
of doing that. Yeah. You know, a lot of
people are like, "Oh, well, he's
different and he is humble and all those
things when um as a Jesuit pope, this is
what he's supposed to do." Yes. Yeah.
Well, he also, you know, is the most one
of the most liberal popes, if not the
most liberal progressive popes that
we've ever had. And he was in the same
time as we had Obama, right? And so, we
had this huge shift to the left globally
as well, right? And now we're shifting
back hard to the right. You have other
at least with our president. Yeah. Well,
across the world you have Argentina with
Javier and Malay, you have Italy as
well, Germany. I mean, you have this
huge shift to the right. And so, I
really think that you're going to have
an incredibly conservative candidate
that becomes the next pope. That's my
guess. That will be a very conservative
candidate, which which lines up with
Bible prophecy. If we are where we think
we are at the end of time, there should
be this huge swing to the right.
One of the things Pope Francis was known
for is his encyclicals. And one of his
uh biggest and most well-known uh
encyclicals was
Latoya. And Latoya was an encyclical
about climate change and care for our
common home basically about how uh
climate change was ruining the world.
Mhm. And he proposed a lot of different
solutions in this long article that he
wrote. Um and there was actually a lot
of hubbub about this encyclical. There
was people that made whole movies about
it. There was all kinds of commentary
and dialogue about this in a lot of
different world settings. One of the
concepts that he introduced though was a
concept of a weekly earth Sabbath.
Um and so he talks about basically
encouraging people to take one day off
to pause so that their their
rest was all synchronized basically on
one day for the care of our common home.
Basically trying to reduce carbon
emissions, reduce you know consumerism
and everything else for one day out of
the week. Does this James what do you
think? Does this concern us as
Protestant Christians? So in revelation
14 we know there's a warning about false
worship of false image name and mark
corresponding to the first four
commandments of the decalogue and
protestants have long recognized you go
back to Thomas Tillum Peter Chamberlain
George Carlo and many others recognizing
Sunday as a counterfeit to God's true
fourth commandment and so it's
interesting to see him start to push
this rhetoric uh we have long expected
Protestant America to lead out in
pushing for that at the end of time. Uh
and they are starting to do that with
Project 2025. There was a video that we
did on that discussing how we've we're
seeing initiatives like that under a
conservative administration beginning to
go that direction. Heritage Foundation
is pushing that direction. But we've
also seen uh you know, we talked earlier
about JD Vance. One of one of the uh
presentations he did with with the St.
Francis University of Stubenville, there
was Dr. Chad Peknold who was calling for
Sunday rest legislation by law there as
well. Uh the book that he wrote uh the
forward for for Kevin Roberts with the
Heritage Foundation Dawn's Early Light.
You can see JD Vance uh talking about uh
or at least in that book referencing uh
the Sabbath rest there as well. So it's
it's interesting to see how Pope
Francis's push here is being heard. His
second uh or his his next encyclical was
Fert Telluti. Uh what did you think
about Fertelllety? Did you read it?
Yeah, I actually, if I remember
correctly, read a leaked German copy a
few hours before it was officially
released back in the day because I was
really curious to see what he promoted
in it. But you can see where he's
reaching across the the aisle to the
Grande Mom of LSR and uh starting to
promote unity there as well. Uh, I
believe that at the end of time, the
devil is marshalling his forces to join
everybody together. And we see that
there's a conflict between the woman of
Revelation 17, all her daughters, and a
remnant in Revelation 14:12, those who
keep the commandments of God and have
the faith of Jesus. What's the
percentage of Catholics currently in the
United States? Like, how much how much
of the population do they make up? I
just happened to look this up before we
came on. It's about 20 to 22%. Okay. So
about a fifth of the United States is
Catholic. But if you look at our Supreme
Court justices, and this is our current
set set of judges here, right? Um look
at their
faiths. Catholic, Catholic, Catholic,
Catholic, Anglican, Catholic, Catholic,
Catholic, Protestant, arguably uh
Jewish. Um now some of these some of
these are better Catholics than other
Catholics. Um but and the one that's
Anglican, he says that he's Anglican
now. He grew up as Catholic and then he
he studied as a Jesuit. And so then he
went to becoming So it's like, well, is
he really Anglican or is he just hiding?
Like
so um you know, you have this this huge
percentage of our Supreme Court is made
up of Catholics. Why? They're only 20 to
22% and yet seven out of nine of them
are Roman Catholic. Mhm. Uh you see
Trump surrounding himself with
Catholics. Um you have even the VP is
Catholic. And who's that sitting there
right next to him? Uh James, do you
recognize that face? Kevin Roberts.
Kevin Roberts. Yeah. Yeah. he created or
he runs currently the Heritage
Foundation has been a huge voice in
creating Project 2025 which wants to I
guess we could say it's it's it's laying
the groundwork for uh future Sunday
legislation, right? And you know the
thing is is a lot of people will say,
"Oh, you're just sitting on one side of
the aisle or the other." And I'm not
coming at this from a Republican or
Democratic side. I'm coming at this from
a Protestant side. Mh. If you look at
Biden, he also had a heavily Catholic
influence as well. He was Catholic. Mhm.
And when he was on as president, there
was also a lot of Supreme Court justices
who were Catholic. Yeah. Yeah. And I I
personally never express my political
views on this channel because I believe
the gospel is for everyone, right? But
people have come after us saying you're
Democrat and I'm like I'm not saying
whatever I am, but I am coming at this
like you said from a Protestant point of
view and I would say a conservative
biblical point of view. Yes. You know,
I'm not liberal. I'm not Democratic. I'm
not Republican. Right. But I am a Bible
believing Christian. Exactly. Right.
Yeah. So I, you know, I don't want to
find myself labeled on either side of
the aisle, if that makes sense. Uh but
you know, there's there's uh a lot of
commentary here about how Trump's
Catholic cabinet, how will their faith
shape their work?
Um you talk about um Trump's cabinet
would be comparable to what has been
called the most Catholic cabinet in
history. His predecessor Joe Biden's
more than a third of Trump's nominees
are Catholic. Mhm. So we know that there
was a there's this massive push towards
cath Catholicism that has happened. Has
that always been the case in our
country?
Have we always seen uh Catholics in
positions of high power? I mean before
Biden, the the only other prior
president that was Catholic was JFK.
So if you talk about
JFK, this is a news article right here
from a newspaper uh that is from 1959
and it talks about uh Senator John F.
Kennedy will announce his White House
aspirations in December against a
background of debate on whether a
Catholic should be elected
president. So back when he was becoming
president, there was this overall
sentiment in America that ah should we
really have a Catholic leader or is he
going to be trying to push Catholic
views, Catholic doctrine, submitting to
the pope for the whole country? Mhm. And
so JFK famously distanced himself and he
believed in complete separation of
church and state and said, "Oh, my
Catholic views are never going to come
into the forefront of my presidency."
You know, th those are not going to
influence me. He was very open that the
papacy would have no influence on his
presidency whatsoever. He also spoke out
against secret societies. Well, shortly
after that, he was assassinated. So, I
mean, you know, we can kind of see where
that
landed. Um but you know how how do we
view this going forward? A pope has
died. Does that mean that anything
significant changes? You know, are we
looking at the papacy? Are we looking at
ooh who's the next pope going to be?
That's what's really going to seal it.
You know, that's what's going to tell us
what's going on. I would wager no. I
would wager what we should be looking at
is where America is headed. Mhm.
Right. We know that the and we actually
did a previous episode talking about how
Washington DC kind of mirrors Rome,
right? Oh, tons. Yeah. And you you know,
you recently went to Washington DC. Did
you see it while you were there? I saw
it and I saw even more things that
wasn't even discussed in that episode. I
was like, "Wow, it is everywhere." And
and a lot of those things that we
discussed that you see here in both in
Rome and DC are actually uh references
to sun worship. Yeah. Yeah. very much
so. But you know, we we know that there
is a beast spoken of in Revelation. Mhm.
And that's not the beast. The the first
beast is not the one that brings about
the mark of the
beast. It's the second beast. It's the
lamblike beast with
horns that speaks as a
dragon. That's the one that brings about
the mark of the beast
crisis. Yeah. Yeah, if you go back to
the early stages of American history
like John Bacon and Isaac Bakus, there
were a couple of Protestants whose works
actually obtained recently from the
Library of Congress, which has both
copies of both of their works. They
identified the second beast of
Revelation uh 13 as the United States of
America.
So from the very foundation of this
country, Protestants have recognized
that the United States is the second
beast power of revelation. Mhm. And if
you think about it, you know, a lamblike
beast, it looks innocent, right? But it
speaks like a dragon. Speaking denotes
authority. So it gets its authority from
the dragon. And look at all of look at
all of our political leaders that are
going and paying homage to the pope
across the world, but especially
Americans are merchants as well. Why
would Elon Musk go and meet with the
Pope? That power had two horns that did
not have crowns on them. Symbolic of
religious and civil liberty. Not no
pope, no king in this country, right?
But uh it's a republican country. It's
one that has had freedom for for a long
time, but uh it speaks like a dragon.
Well, you know, you also study further
in Revelation, you find out there are
daughters of the harlot and they go back
and they they support the harlot, right?
And so we know that those
daughters, women in Bible prophecy are a
representation of a church. So if you
have a harlot, we know that that's the
main mother church, right? And Bab and
uh the the Catholic Church has long held
that it's the mother church. It's come
out and said that, right? Yeah. It's
literally inscribed outside of St. John
of Latin. Mutter, right? Mutter. So, so
it is the mother church. So then who are
the daughters that support it? Well,
it's all these Protestant denominations
that have kind of well, yeah, we went
away, but now we're going to go back,
you know, we're going to we're going to
ecumenically come together. What's
interesting from Pope Francis's legacy
is because he went liberal like he did
there has been a backlash in the United
States of a lot of traditional Catholics
who want to return to traditional values
and some of the rhetoric coming out of
those channels like Michael Voris with
church militant is a call to bring back
the Inquisition to call religious
liberty a snake coiled up under the the
the table here in the United States. In
other words, the backlash from Pope
Francis, and this may have may have been
intentional, is to reinvigorate those
traditionalists who would be more than
happy to come along and take away
liberty because at the end of the day,
Rome called religious liberty and
Mirarivos and Quantura a pest,
insanity, a delirmentum.
Religious liberty to Rome is a pest,
right? And that that that goes back to
Gregory uh in Mirarivos and Pope Pius
the nights and cyclical uh the the the
errors of liberalism. Yeah. So um you
know I think this is a lot of food for
thought for a lot of people and I just
want to um mention again for those at
home who want to do a deeper study into
this um we got a whole video literally
just looking at scripture as to who the
antichrist is which we believe as
Protestants. And this is an ancient
belief among Protestants, among
reformers, among many of the former
reformers out of which came all these
various denominations. They all believed
the papacy, the seat of the papacy, not
Pope Francis, but the seat of the papacy
is the antichrist. Um, so we got a video
on that link in description. We got a
video on what we believe the mark of the
beast is according to scripture as well.
We got a video on um how the second
beast in Revelation 13 is in fact the
United States and how they will be part
of enforcing the mark of the beast. Um
and we got even a video on uh who the
pilgrims believe the antichrist was. The
pilgrims came to coming to United States
and also on um what 666 actually means
and the Babylonian bale origins of that.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comment below, and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]